good to be back in New York what what
memories come to mind when you come back
to New York all kinds really I mean
every time I fly in honestly it feels
like you're kind of flying home do you
ever get in trouble like you ever got
any good stories when you were I lived
in Jersey I was married early
oh thanks really so I was kind of stayed
under the radar for the most part that
really wasn't my personality really just
kind of go to the ballpark wildest
player you played with though while
though did you live vicariously through
vicariously through who's wild because
she had characters on that yeah I'd say
I'd say goose is probably the wildest
guy I played with who was just that he
was a kind of anti what I would think of
myself who would say he says anything he
thinks about says it loud
ultra-competitive
just like he's kind of that that figure
but he's also he's one of those the
baseball purists too and like a
relievers a real reliever when you're
pitching three innings there and you
know these guys who come in for you know
nine pitches he has a problem with those
save numbers doesn't he
he's definitely strong his strong
opinions and goosh is loud but you know
he's passionate I mean that's goose and
that's the great thing about goose you
may not totally agree with his opinions
but he's got him and he says them that's
the way he feels
what kind of Yankee memorabilia do you
still have lots of stuff lots of stubble
it's actually in storage but lots of
stuff from Mickey Mantle balls
Jody bats
you know yogi stuff like just stuff that
you meet these guys and you get a chance
to grab a ball at old-timers day and you
and you and you get one song what was
you throw in the box and it's still
there now it's in storage what was it
like meeting Mickey Mantle Mickey was
great he was like a guy's guy he was
like one of those guys that was you know
a kid are you doing you could tell the
way his camaraderie with his own
teammates at old-timers day you could
tell they loved Mickey yeah he's one of
the boys
what about Jody so he was a little
different he was a little quieter and
seemed almost shy to a point where and
so I don't you know I don't I didn't
know him well sit on
Deus or two with him with I remember
Keith Keith Hernandez and I I think it
was the Baseball Writers Association
dinner and we sit with Joe and Keith I
think Joe's from San Francisco Keith
young grew up in that area he s Joe all
kinds of questions OHS counting down and
he really wasn't talking and Heath
finally said what you'd like to do with
the plate and Joe in like to get right
on top of a plate and pull everything
and he started talking hitting you know
and that was kind of cool to see him
open up and talk a little bit who was
this smartest guy you ever sat down and
talked hitting - Oh a lot of guys I
think like for me Lou Pinella taught me
more about hitting and how hitting works
than anyone probably the smartest guy
sit down with it was was Ted Williams
you got that opportunity yeah Ted and
myself and Boggs they did a thing in
Sports Illustrated years ago talking
hitting that's when the weight shift was
coming in and in the Charlie Lau and in
Walt Hriniak you know Ted was kind of
like no you don't shift weight it was a
it was a pretty cool conversation with
Peter Gammons would you have a different
launch angle now with your swing I don't
think so because that seems to be and do
you believe in that launch angle is why
the reason here's what I believe I
believe that you should hit certain
balls out of the ballpark
right you know what I mean I mean if the
pitch is there and you hit it with the
with the proper technique it's going out
of the ballpark
I don't believe in practicing launch
angle because I think that lengthens
your swing and we're seeing a change in
the game now guys talking about launch
angle pitchers are throwing the ball up
and and now that's there's gonna be a
weapon of up there up there until guys
will make that adjustment either leaving
that alone but I believe in like there's
a difference in practicing launch angle
and trying to get the ball in the air
right if I'm hitting line drives in BP
at 60 miles an hour that may relate to
getting the ball in the air at 95
because if you're trying to get the ball
in the air at 95 you're at 60 you're
lengthening your swing and batting
practice and now when you get to the
game at 95 you're not catching up with
that but you've got this Jordan Hicks
dude throwing 105 the other day I mean
yeah but do you believe that it's
actually 105 I'm sure it is sure it's
probably you know I'm but I'd probably
also believe that
93 in my day was probably 96 or
something oh you know when Ryan went
through over a hundred right I'm sure it
was you know I think used to him didn't
yeah I did but I face him at forty four
and you still had to gear it up no he
was one of those guy you better turn up
the knob a little bit when you face
Enola so and it was like forty four and
and and not in a negative way but I
faced Eve Carleton and Tom Seaver when
they were older and it was not the same
they changed the way they pitched but
Nolan was still a power pitcher at in
the forties but who's the guy that you
you you went in and he had to he had to
buckle up because he was bringing cheese
Roger in 86 Clemens well that was a
magical year there yeah he was that was
a different yeah that was different that
was a power year where he was just
spotting up the heater he could get
everywhere he wanted to go with it
no one you had to gear it up all the
time rainy Johnson he had to gear it up
there was a few guys that you had to
turn off the knob did you face Gooden
yeah a little bit but bring training
more oh okay I didn't have the
interleague so spring trained but it
wasn't the same no no it was two pitches
right no it was good don't doc was good
I remember facing doc you know we were
both kind of the same we were both young
yeah right so uh and I didn't mind
hitting the fastball so it was a you
know a guy that really threw hard didn't
really bother me at all but doc was like
I really want to be calm you know with
him because the ball jumps at you and
then the breaking ball you don't want to
be trying to gear up hit the heat or you
just want to relax no cheats' of the
heater then the breaking ball sits there
for you a little bit did you ever feel
overwhelmed like Kruk did in the
all-star game with Randy Johnson in the
playoffs and I shouldn't say overwhelmed
because I was swinging about really good
in 95 at the end but but Randy had too
much for me really yeah he get to a
point where when when he was thrown when
he couldn't get the slider over when I
when he was younger I know I'm getting a
fastball you know at that point I'm
hitting the fastball was this when he
was in Montreal
no no he was in Seattle okay you
wouldn't get in the slide over early on
okay right and then when he started
getting the slider over there really was
no where to hit it for me though really
the only place to hit the slider was
like down the third-base line
and who's gonna try to hit Randy Johnson
down the third-base line when the ball
it's it's really it's just on you so
fast so that that series I was swinging
really good
when he gets the slider over it was just
like there's nothing I can do what's
that release point was he even gone out
further left against the left-handed
batter like he was gonna use that frame
no it's out there it was out there
pretty good it was just so hard dan I'm
serious it was just like he let it go I
was like oh that's too late I'm too late
quick it was it really it felt like it
like if you're thinking slider inside
cuz you're scooting out here it's like
that's already on me right and that's
just you're too late almost all the time
what kind of eyesight do you have
because I wanted to do a story on great
eyesight and how it's beneficial for
hitters because you can wear glasses or
contacts but there are guys who just
have naturally good eyesight I think I
was like you know one of those 2015 guys
okay you know I'd seen in and I think it
was helped me I was dominant front side
right eye right I was dominant do you
remember your first at-bat
no you know what maybe well I think it
great memories I think it's Jim Slayton
okay I think it was Jim Slaton and and I
seen Jim pitch I'm from Evansville right
so he pitched a triple-a with the Tigers
or as maybe as the Brewers in so I hit
up he throws me a fastball that I pop up
and I'm like man I'm gonna hit here I
popped up a fastball and then Jim was
with the Dodgers later when I was
coaching and then you realize the
pitching was gonna get a whole lot
better
you have your welcome to the major
leagues moment uh for me the moment you
mean you mean just getting to the big no
just where you'd go like either it's
really good or it's gonna be really
difficult
you know guys talk about that where it's
a welcome to the NBA and they're
guarding LeBron or Michael Jordan er did
you ever have I say one of my the moment
for me was probably meeting Rod Carew at
the 84 all-star game in San Francisco
you know making the team is kind of a
rookie guys I played partially in 83 rod
was one of my heroes as a kid I wanted
to be just like
hit the ball all over the ballpark hit
for average always love that and when I
got a chance
I made the all-star team Rod head he
gave me a bat when I got there with he
had signed it for me he must have read
that I'd said something about no that's
nice everything in it for me I was like
he's Don Mattingly joining us in the man
cave the Marlins manager lost to the
Mets yesterday next game will be at well
tonight at 7:10 Eastern are you having
it how much fun you have I'm having a
lot of fun I mean you don't like when we
when we get into streaks we've lost some
games in a row
that part is has been hard what we're
doing is it is exhilarating honestly I
think Derek coming in and what he's set
forth for us with the building in the
system through the minor leagues how
we're gonna play a clear direction and
you feel like we're gonna get somewhere
and it's gonna be special when we get
there are they gonna be patient though
with you oh I don't know in that that's
part you don't worry about you know what
I mean you do your best you try to
develop these kids and it's always been
I'm always about I want to make my
players as good as they can possibly be
and if we can build them and develop
them and I'm not the right guy for the
next step then then so be it but would
you rather and maybe this is an obvious
answer but would you rather have youth
that you're teaching and have more hands
on as opposed to a veteran lineup you
know you have the Dodgers where you know
the expectations were high there's a big
payroll there you go now you got to win
the World Series I mean as a as a coach
and a teacher you know you like the
young guys for the you know but you
don't like them better than the old guys
right know the guys it was some
experience because I had both in LA
started off when I went out there with
Joe you know it's Ethier and Kemp and
Russell Martin and a whole group of
young young guys Kershaw all these guys
are coming along right in that that's
fun to help those guys but it's also
nice when Manny walks in the door out
there and drives in 50 runs in 50 days
and comes into the cage and does some
things that you've been talking about
about keeping it simple stay in the
middle of the field and you see Manny
come in and just do his thing and then
your young guys maybe pay attention to
what you're talking about a little bit
more when did you know Kershaw was going
to be Kershaw
hmm pretty much right away my sunroom
with Preston room with Clayton
they were both rookie ball together and
he told me right oh he's dead I could
pitch in a big league right now and what
does he know he's 18 yeah whatever but
then a couple years later when I go over
to the Dodgers from the Yankees and
Clayton comes over and pitches in a
spring training game gives up a homer I
think early two pools maybe his first
guy he faces and then the next guy comes
right back out after and you go this
kid's gonna be you know you see that
when a guy gets hit he doesn't back away
comes right back it's like a young kid
Seager coming up you steam come over and
spring training out of the minor league
camp his first swing as a full out let
it go high fastball he fouls it back and
you're like this is gonna be you can see
it right away would you be okay now if
you were playing with a hundred and
fifty strikeouts absolutely not but
today's men remember it was embarrassing
if you struck out a hundred times right
yeah I get it but I just think there's a
value some value to you know putting the
ball in play but I see both sides right
you see the side that says don't just
spread out play pepper and peck balls to
the infielder and give up your whole
swing and so I see that mentality and
there's times you want to keep keep
swinging the bat and I think there's a
there's a happy medium I know for myself
I didn't really strike out at all early
on I would really like choked up and
want to put the ball in play as I played
a little bit longer I knew I could
pretty much have my at-bat just change
my thinking a little bit where I'm
looking for the ball what I'm trying to
cover still have an aggressive at-bat
and still in really keep the strikeouts
down but but if you look at what these
guys are doing now it's it's either
everybody's throwing 97 98 and
everybody's swinging for a home run
right I mean that's that's but I mean in
general right seems like that yes but it
feels like it's okay if you strike out
in sabbatic Badge of Courage if you
strike 150 times like hey you got your
cuts up there yeah 150 seems kind of
okay right it seems you guys getting up
to 200 yeah it's tough and I think you
can have that
guy you can't have three or four of
those guys you know if you can like a
guy that strikes out one hundred eighty
hundred ninety two hundred times but
he's hitting 45 and he's walking in some
yeah right so he's least he's getting on
base if you have three of those guys at
three or four those guys in your lineup
you're gonna go through games we just
don't even put the ball in play hardly
you know and you can't score runs you
get a guy to third you can't stick going
I think there's got to be there's gonna
be a mix of guys that can it's hard to
find now a guy that can just true hit
like you see pure hit but that can use
the whole field round can yeah that's
some saying there's a there's a few guys
out there but would you rather if they
were stocks would you invest in trout or
Bryce Harper uh well that's a tough one
either one of those guys you take for me
I think I'm probably more of a trout guy
I love Bryce because he's a great player
and he plays really hard
trout seems more day-in day-out
even keel just kind of keeps going
steady as the ship goes not quite as it
doesn't seem as as exciting because the
way Bryce plays is exciting and it
happens fast you know harp I mean try
just keeps kind of cruising along
goodness goodness it's old school yeah
but I mean not so much I mean plays he
has fun when you watch him play he's got
a smile on his face
he's a vibe tool guy you know that
that's another thing I mean not that
Harper's not a great price price the
same guy the same guy right
trout's better he's more consistent that
that's what you see as far as the day-in
day-out yes but but that's what I want I
think I think Harper can give you bigger
moments but I think trout is gonna give
you something that you know you plug in
every single day kind of way you know
it's you take trout's okay I get Harper
alright I'll let you have the first
pitcher then what picture do you want
right now right now oh not sure who I
would take right now I gotta think about
that one a little bit alright you waited
too long I'll take Scherzer this moment
night I'll still take her stall okay
I believe I believe in this guy you know
he's one of em but max is a handful all
right you did you were part of the Bar
Mitzvah video for this a couple of years
ago Fritzi son and I don't know if you
were told how many people were involved
in the Bar Mitzvah I don't think so
because there were 48 celebrities
involved in the Bar Mitzvah Donny that's
good I'm one of 48 you were wonderful
better about that only a few of them
were baseball it was from all walks of
life but I don't know how you presented
this to Donny I presented it is that
that my son Jordan would love to have a
bar mitzvah congratulatory message if he
gets an opportunity to take a moment to
do that for the special video montage
this is how it looked and sounded here
this is Don Mattingly oh no Gordon how
you doing Don Mattingly happy bar mitts
my friend and what is it Mazel Tov throw
like a shot glass or something right now
that I don't think that's all right yeah
you got those glasses here right you
were you were at home that was a that
was a that was not the house I'm living
in now and that's that house we had
redid that kitchen too so I like to make
sure we know that that wallpaper and
back we got was very awesome yeah
one of 48 celebrities to be part of the
exclusive club feel good about that as
long as you're you only you know like 50
my son loved it that was so cool did you
do see we brought in two mannequin the
Don Mattingly mannequin I see that I
like it now we had every time you get
thrown from a game when you were with
the Dodgers you would send in piece of
clothing so we into your hat with your
socks with your pants everything but
your jockstrap I think two pairs of
pants and then we got the Florida
Marlins when you got tossed you sent us
the jersey over there yeah and we got
the Hat have you gotten tossed uh no not
this year I'm over that Dan can you get
tossed tonight just I think the last
time I said I know did you think about
that as you went out absolutely not I
didn't think one bit about it but yeah I
don't know what happens I don't know
what
ones out there have you ever been have
you ever asked to be thrown no you would
never do that no no I I've wanted to a
couple of times I've told Wally the
bench because I said I'm getting ready I
gotta go this is sixth inning were down
12 runs us I'm gonna go get started on a
beer here also we have a fan boy here
and scene O'Connor I now Seaton you have
to walk over to Donnie to ask this
because you tried to do this when nobody
was watching or listening so I said if
you're gonna ask for something from
Donnie then you have to do it on the
show yeah well I saw my brother growing
up we were huge Yankee fans and he's he
truly loves baseball he loves the game
he watches constantly he's gotten on
five screens but growing up as a kid he
was a huge Don Mattingly fan and you
were you know you're talking about Rod
Carew and sort of modeling your game
after it we spent a lot of you know
afternoons in our backyard trying to
copy your batting stance although uh I
don't think he was a lefty put either
way so yeah I I tried to talk him into
coming in today
yeah to just kind of hang out and make
your day even more awkward for you but
yes I was wondering if I could get an
autograph for him since he said he was I
was like Dave you should come in and
talk to say hi to Donnie and he was just
like no I would never do that to you I
couldn't make it that awkward so I was
hoping that I could come home with an
autograph for him it'd be great if
Donnie said no he didn't come in so I
wouldn't sign on yeah yeah yeah it's
like you tell kids you get somewhere
you're in a line and they just look at
you they won't put they won't ask
[Laughter]
Halloween now nobody even says
trick-or-treat anymore say it trick or
treat
did you ask for autographs when you
played I asked for like I would trade
bats oh I'd like to trade bats with guys
like George Brett guys I like Jim Rice
different guys I would tree I would like
to like a autographed bats were some
what do you have so you had these
showcased in your house I do not on
storage with with the first change the
first divorce overage you didn't lose
any of that stuff in the divorce no I
gotta keep the memorabilia Oh might you
know
stuff but it they don't soul the bats in
half and like your ex-wife gets half
there's nothing no that's good seaton do
you want to bring the gear over here for
Donnie to sign
oh yeah would you do that sure cool her
yeah yeah where's the weirdest place
you've been approached to sign something
probably a bathroom but would you yeah
or they want to shake your hand as
you're coming out of the bathroom as
well that's an old one so dreams come
true right that's what he does that's
yeah I didn't get any Donnie can you
make my mortgage payment hey it's great
to see you and glad you're having fun
and hopefully you don't get tossed
tonight who are you facing tonight with
the mess do you even know ya wheeler oh
yeah you own wheeler well we haven't
facing too much no I know I just yeah
throw that out there spark something get
some controversy gone yeah get you
thrown out of a game here Continental
Tire Coach's Corner the Marlins manager
Don Mattingly we are back to close up
shop here in New York right after this
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]